that's funny because that was one of the
the scenes between uh
one of the volunteers and one of the
women that lived in the uh community i
think she was in her late seventies i
think was yeah
oh annette i'm sorry i'm sorry um and so
she was looking at her
uh grandchildren's photos and was like
oh a little surprise and yeah the
volunteers like that's why i just had
photos of me running through the meadows
helping poor people and it was great
um
one thing you mentioned in the film is
that the older generation seems
to be more reserved and doesn't want to
be as boastful where of course now it's
all about promoting yourself
in this new you know online world so
how was that seeing the two worlds you
know contrasted
the more polite not wanting to be too
forward whereas you know now anything
basically goes yeah
well again the younger people grew up
with the internet so they're kind of
used to this idea of posting their
status updates posting their photos
blasting themselves all over the
internet because everybody's doing that
so it's the norm whereas for older
people they're not used to it so it
seems very forward to be posting photos
of yourself and adding people on
facebook who you don't even know that
well in real life
well i know with annette she also had a
really excellent point which i thought
was incredibly um
astute of her to notice because she
wasn't very reversed in facebook but she
said oh adding or dropping a friend this
is where these machines quote her
terminology get very dangerous because
people feel insulted and the volunteer
that helped he said oh it's not that big
a deal because she said oh no no this is
where
it and i i wonder do you think that
connections these days maybe aren't as
serious
as maybe that generation where
you really locked in
this is your friend and you keep them
for a long time where things now are
more
transient you know we're just sort of in
and out oh let's add this person or yeah
drop them well definitely i think that
because the main reason for the seniors
getting online was to connect with
family they weren't that interested in
connecting with
acquaintances they weren't very
interested in meeting new friends online
which a lot of young people are totally
comfortable doing
it was just it wasn't something that
interested them it was like oh why don't
you chat with this person why would try
online dating and some of them went for
it but it never really clicked for them
it was
that's fine that was funny and fun but
my main reason is 100 to speak with my
family
you